hey guys welcome to the evident caitlyn
podcast the podcast that Caitlin's doing
the intro for today yay good show myself
so today we are gonna talk about jobs we
had when we were teenagers / maybe early
twenty-something sisters bleed into that
mind it a little bit ah
I worked I'm not good with ages you know
how about I college you're in high
school I worked in high school
and then I the first summer after
college I worked a normal job and then I
went to internships okay so so we
thought it'd be fun to talk about like
our our old jobs I know we've talked
about like our corporate post college
type jobs before but we were streaming
the other day and we have this thing
where if people gift subs to other
people then the rule is like anyone who
receives a gifted sub has to do a good
deed and we were like what would good
deeds be and one of the suggestions was
like be nice to someone in retail oh
yeah that made us think about our both
we both have had retail jobs yeah so
that made us think of like art we
chitchat it a little bit about our
retail jobs and we're like you know what
we should say it we should say this good
when you do a podcast on this because we
funny to tell stories people have been
wanting to hear at kailyn's Hot Topic
stories for a while well on the stream I
don't know if people in the podcast know
that I worked at Hot Topic
Oh it all comes out but first a few what
new things so what new so one of the
things I've been melting our minds and
making our words even harder that's the
wrong moving on is all the tax stuff
we've been dealing with oh you know our
tax stuff has become so complicated we
even hired an accountant someone to help
us yeah for the first time we hired an
accountant and like but so much still is
on you even with an accountant it's not
good to say like hey they need
information from you you need to
organize your books you still needed to
make everything you know I think that's
why I resisted well also because I'm
cheap and I don't have hands but I think
that's why I
listed and I like getting an accountant
for so long cuz I was like we're still
gonna have to do like 99% of the work
but isn't it so great having an expert
it does and I can be like if I do this
is it illegal is it legal and she's like
that's illegal I'm like so it is crazy
learning all of this that we learn and
we certainly don't want to give out tax
advice because from state to state I
could just give so many caveats of why
we can't give so we will not have a tax
ox advice podcast but it's so easy to
break the law when like the way the
systems are set up it's like there's so
much responsibility on you the
individual for something that's so
important and the punishments are so
high and it's so complicated you know
yeah but but also the rules change all
the time like not as year-to-year like
multiple times throughout the year yeah
like like just last year at the end of
last year there's a thing called the
Wayfarer case yeah so what you have no
Wayfarer it's like there's some
furniture decoration kind of place and
the way it works when you sell stuff
online is it used to be like you only
have to charge and remit sales tax for
States you have a nexus in which is like
a big enough presence in and there was
some case against Wayfarer that was one
where now it's like it doesn't matter if
you have Nexus or not if you make a
certain amount of money on any state you
have to pay that state's taxes so
instead of just like for example let's
say you sell stuff online and you live
in Texas let's say you sell stuff on
Etsy and you live in Texas you'd only
have a nexus in Texas that's how it used
to be that's how you speak now it's like
a few sells over a certain amount and
granted you'd have to be a pretty big
business because it's very high
thresholds maybe so over certain amount
you got to register your business and
every single state yeah and like that
just happened a few months ago and no
one knows how to do it yeah you know
those are some things if you sell any
product there are no thresholds if you
sell any sale in that state
collect state sales tax and remit it to
that state even if you sell like five
bucks so like don't stall stuff in
Kansas anybody I think I'm not sure all
the rules check your own I think it's
just crazy but but also Seguin is so
much it's like with the with the web
it's great the web so many things
probably when you used to just have a
physical store everything was pretty
understood but now you can just open a
Shopify website start collecting taxes
or not cut taxes both of which could be
wrong and start selling stuff and then
you can get sued yeah if you don't do it
right yeah government come after you for
accidentally and it just seems like
there's a lot of conflicting information
anyways all of that to say our brains
have been melting we've been dealing
with a lot of tax stuff we're really
trying to actually simplify it now we're
moving to a new merch system I'm not
sure when we're going to announce that
or when that's gonna be done or what
have you but if you've been to shop Evan
Kalin calm recently but all of that's
for tax reasons so we're really trying
to set ourselves up so that this isn't
as big of a thing constantly and at the
end of the year so we can just make we
just want to make videos thrown in jail
please we're not trying to do things
wrong it's just very complicated yeah
also I've been kind of on a quest I've
been on a quest to upgrade all of our
things as you guys might have noticed
you know like firfer the whole journey
of our channel you know it's like it's
like recently we got our cameras
upgraded that's probably what three
months ago no that was like over six
months oh my gosh so it took me a long
time to get to the second step which is
audio oh by the way guys odd oh my gosh
we have these amazing keyboards the
people here you can go ahead and just
that the people want looking at the
YouTube videos mechanical we've replaced
some of the keys so kaitlin's is unique
and mine is unique and they have
personality those are the two default
colors that came when we're playing like
Astra norm in the future minecraft Java
or whatever we're doing here like we're
slowly getting things more and more
setup so one thing I recently tackled
was improving our audio for our main
channel videos which has been a thing
that's bothering us
ever since we started the channel
listening to our old videos it's so
painful
we've been improving for a while but now
I think this is probably the biggest set
forward in our audio because we spent a
lot of money yeah so you you um it the
videos that are out at the time of this
podcast coming out and none of them have
the new audio yet it won't be till after
but I'm really excited to film our first
day the very first one might have to do
with a plant wall or grass wall yeah
yeah so you know and the funny thing is
it improves partway through that video
we did the intro with the old mics like
those so rage-inducing the mics are
really acting up that day and we just
like we just pulled the trigger on like
the expensive fritters right then right
nope cannot deal with this anymore
and so finally got the new ones yeah so
those are there's some things oh I have
a funny story what's that well you know
it but you guys don't know what that's
so like jube usually at night she'll
sleep next to me and that's like her
typical spot occasionally she'll be on
the couch I know it's all you're gonna
go it's pretty rare that she's not
snuggled next to me and then there's and
she also like she sleeps all the way
through the night like she's not off
playing and stuff like she's a really
hard sleeper and um she also does tend
to wake me up in the morning that's
called the kitty alarm but she's very
polite and she doesn't really start
doing it until like 8:30 or 9:00 and so
anyways the other day like we were
sleeping and we heard this
scratching noise and she does that when
she wants to get into a room that has a
closed door scratching look around
like what like did we do we accidentally
like closed the office and she was in
the office overnight like is she where
is she and we're looking around we're
looking like in the bathroom and the
room stuck her in the hallway and then I
was like wait and I open Evans drawer
and she is in the drawer
she's like my dresser drawer yeah she
spent the night in the dresser drawer
and like so it was my fault
cuz I was putting up our swimsuits like
we there's some suits out to dry and I
was putting them up the night before and
I had opened your drawer to put your
swimsuit here you know you had it open
for like for like a second brief moment
single thing but she is dark like the
night and the shadows and she's a sneaky
quiet ninja so fun must have jumped in
like I just don't understand how she got
past me or like did I get distracted and
like check my phone with the drawer open
and then close I don't know what
happened I don't know how she got in
there she seemed perfectly content she
was just like that was a good sleep I'm
awake now time for my breakfast let me
out
yeah let me out she's very calm she's
very calm socially so loved it because
she loves being in tiny enclosed spaces
so she's I could just sleep in here
tonight
my favorite spot I just like it's just
such a weird mystery I don't how she got
past me I I feel like guard her at times
like when she's in the mood where she
wants to hop in the dresser she really
wants cap yeah and she used to like and
we again we've gotten better just
watching her but I even like the
bathroom drawers like if you have it
open she wants to get in there and then
squeeze herself through the door drawer
and then behind it and then sit on the
drawer below it and then you're like I
can't shut this drawing out because
you're sitting there and she's looking
out at you but then she gets kind of
stuck so you have to take out the
drawers
thirdly cats yeah alright so we have a
few jobs we can talk about Kalyan worked
at Hot Topic and she did characters kick
caricature whatever moving on okay well
yeah we carry I did characters at Fiesta
Texas yes specifically yeah which is
like a Six Flags yeah and then I worked
as a lifeguard and I worked at the
pottery studio which of these do we want
to do first we go like an order yeah do
you wanna um do you well I don't want to
do in order because I want to talk about
caricatures second okay do you want to
start with one of yours yeah I'll start
with lifeguard because I think that I
probably started working first between
the two of us because I started working
at fifteen years old
oh yeah you totally beat me I didn't
start working till I was like 17 yeah so
the strange thing is that if you want to
work as a lifeguard you can start when
you're fifteen that is kind of weird
right right when I think of like my
cousin's that are that young I'm like
mm-hmm I mean lives could be in your
hands you I mean you were a very tall
fifteen year old I'm sure and and I was
swimming I got in high school by that
point and I was a really really strong
swimmer I'd been swimming my whole life
I was qualified for the job because I
could lift someone out I was strong
enough for that I could lift someone out
of the pool if they needed to be pulled
out for a certain reason or I could do
all of like the things that were
required of of us but the strange thing
is as before I was even fifteen I'm
gonna have I told you this story so
before I got my lifeguard certification
in the US we were actually living in
Saudi Arabia and Riyadh and there's
something called the bronze medallion
which is the Australians version of the
Red Cross which is the US Life Guards
it's like Red Cross but way more
syllables and way more intense Australia
oh yeah things are more intense I guess
so it's like you had to swim all this
like you know yeah just from a long
distance with your clothes on like the
instructor would like come at you and
try to grab you and yank you under and
you had to escape from him and like do
all these exercises well but that's
something that happens like that's like
very very likely thing to happen if some
jumps into a pool and you go to try to
save them if they're yeah that's so true
so so I got this like bronze medallion
when I was like 14 I couldn't I couldn't
work overseas but here my brother was
getting certified so I got all do do
that seems kind of cool I just did it I
don't know why just for fun and I passed
the test I got it I don't know what good
it did me I just have a little medal but
um so I thought that's what lifeguard he
might be in the US so I was like that's
kind of cool
so I tried out for it in the US and you
only had to some like 500 meters or
something like that it was like nothing
it was like it was like CPR and stuff
right
yeah but CPR is just like there's no
like CPR isn't super physical I think
that almost anyone can do CPR and I
guess in the in the area that we're in
there's just like very small pools so I
guess it makes sense you don't need to
swim like 2,000 meters with your clothes
on under a certain time or something I'm
not sure what that feeling was one but I
pretty intense it took like hours for
the test in overseas and in the US there
I was way easier in the u.s. to get
certified so I'm like oh so it's like
you're 15 there's a very easy like
there's low barrier to entry oh my god
it's crazy yeah I wonder if it's
different if you're lifeguarding by an
ocean oh yeah oh it's way more intense
by the oceans yeah yeah there's like rip
tides and you might have just went a lot
further oh yeah no no fur for ocean
lifeguards is it's way more intense and
there's a lot more yeah yeah fur for
ocean lifeguards house there's a whole
training program there's like it's a
whole like thing to get trained up as a
lifeguard you you like take a
months-long thing okay there's a totally
different thing plus in the oceans the
one you drive boats you drive buggies
yeah so no no you're safe don't worry
but surprisingly the low bar we
we live for pool lifeguards you know
it's funny is the pool your life
guarding at was the pool across the
street from my house but you started the
summer we moved yeah oh that's a crazy
story we almost lived near each other
yeah and we wouldn't we were we would
have in the December school district so
I'm not sure if we would have ever met
what if we had a met at state art
competition did you say to our
competition I did some sort of art
something I went to the state science
fair no I went to the state science
competition art competition I might have
done that too I did do some art stuff I
just don't remember like what school it
was at so many schools so many schools
we both moved a lot I'm not sure if you
heard that episode but we in the same
city yeah like around the same age it
was just you started working the same
like the same summer or the same year we
moved yeah so we like I barely met you
but I would have been at that pool
that's great though for me I just like
have so many pleasant memories actually
of lifeguarding because I loved the pool
I love swimming I love being outdoors
but also with the pool right there you
know I loved outdoor and you know in
Houston it's really really hot
especially during the summer but if you
have a pool right there it's the perfect
match as a lifeguard can you like hop in
frequently though so in most pools that
you know there's there's the mega pools
where there's like a whole rotation but
most pools I worked at were small little
local pools where there were two or max
three people but most that I was just
two people and so one person was on the
stand and one person was off and you
would either check people in or you
would maintain the pool or you would do
whatever and at any time you could
pretty much hop in and cool off but if
you're off-duty if you're on duty that's
a whole another thing but when you're
off duty yeah you can like clean the
pool you can just get in that and clean
the pool or you know you can hop in when
you want to if you want to cool off you
can't just use the pool recreationally
but yeah you can hop in yeah just but I
just have so many memories because often
times when you're
if the bathrooms are clean if the
chlorine is up-to-date if everything is
good and you're just there checking
people in but no one's coming in yeah I
just read a lot in the off period I'll
just go to work and I'd read my books
does it go in a fantasy land and like it
would be hot but I hop in the pool I
thought you said fancy hey some of the
books I read have fancy lance suit you
know get fantasy lands or fantasy land
yeah but my favorite thing is when like
lightning happened or storms happen and
we got to kick everybody out and I get
us read and it was like summer storms
witness raining and like you're just
reading at work it was great even even
as we go go or not someone who was
working at the pool yeah I still really
liked and it rained and you were at the
pool for some reason even though you
have to get out there's just something
about like you and your friends get out
and you go under the umbrellas and it's
like well we just gotta eat snacks and
it's just kind of like warm so good a
lot of really good memories from
lifeguarding there are some bad memories
and yeah I mean that's that's the job I
know but I dunno if it like happened
like on your on your watch three three
summers yeah it happened multiple times
and the scariest thing is they're all
kids and all accidents were from parents
not being good parents I mean I this I
hate to say that but like like you know
we are there as overwatch we are there
to you know make sure people don't
injure themselves but if you know that
your kid can't swim don't just like let
them in the water let them run into the
deep end and drown you know I mean
there's there's some people like like
and and I you know the first time that
happens you're a but then honestly
they're having multiple times I just
like looked at that person I knew that
they were gonna do it and I you know we
could help prevent stuff like this from
happening later on but there's one time
with this little girl walked in and she
was like yeah pool and she runs and she
jumps in and she's like drowning
understand this is the very first pool
you've ever seen and you've just like
seeing people use pools in the movies
and you just don't understand like maybe
three first I say like her parents did I
mean obviously she didn't understand he
and her parents like I'm not sure what
her parents were doing but they didn't
like hopping after her and she was like
jumped in and just immediately started
down shouting but not like immediately
start drowning but she was coughing she
was struggling she couldn't keep her
head above water all this oh yeah
that's so crazy so crazy and then like
another time there was I'm wondering how
to tell the story without seeming
attacking but there was a group of
adults and they were all standing around
like I'm not sure if they were just
drinking juice boxes or if there's wine
boxes or whatever belly they're just
having like like adult chitchat time
while their kids played but one of their
kids was like one and they had their
backs turned to their kids and their
kids were on the steps and then the kid
like walked forward and you know it's
like you have a lot of people to keep
track of you have to keep track of all
these people and there's all these
strategies you can like count them and
make sure you see a constant amount of
heads in the water and then a head if
you're counting you're like wait I just
counted 15 and now there's 14 there's a
head missing where's person go you know
so stressful you have to scan back and
forth because one person was in charge
of maintaining the whole pool where we
were at I scan back and this kid is like
facedown in the water all the adults are
like just chit-chatting and I had to
jump in and I have to give like you know
a little bit of assistance to the cab
and I'm like the mom was like so upset
and she called her husband and she ran
off to the emergency room even though
the kid is fine but like I'm like I
don't know like there are some moments
still still a lot of good memories from
it yeah but the worst part is like how
serious the job is you know it's like
it's a lot of responsibility to take on
when you're
it's pretty chill but like when you're
on it's you know a lot of responsibility
and you know after a period of time you
could kind of know who was good who was
bad and who you'd have to like look out
for more so there were periods where it
wasn't too stressful well then there are
a lot of little kids in the pool you're
just like oh my gosh don't don't get in
trouble little kids oh my gosh yeah so
that was that was lifeguarding I did
that for a while um it was a it was a
good job I think the main thing is often
times with these intro jobs you can't
get enough hours you can't get like work
enough to make some serious income
minimum wage yeah minimum wage sometimes
like anything you that that's kind of
what you want to a certain degree like
in high school you don't want to work
all the time like seven days a week
during during the summer break so unless
you really need to or if you want to but
like the gaming experience it's kind of
like a nice little bit of extra freedom
like you don't have to well some people
they need to or like didn't you start
saving up for a college or for like our
personal experience yeah we were lucky
enough that it was like more about
getting the experience yeah um but yeah
that sounds very stressful sometimes
love um my well I guess I'll talk about
my first job um it was really my first
job it's not so weird yeah it was my
first job was um I worked at Six Flags
and I was a caricature artist oh wow I
thought it was my first hot top at first
no cuz I don't have an open wife no I
did I did caricatures there's like a few
kids um like a couple of kids in my
school that did it that I was friends
with um and I was like that'd be kind of
cool you know it was like my art friends
mm-hm and the like it was it was like
kind of a scary job to do is your first
job because there's like a performance
aspect to me mm-hmm which I'm he's not a
scariest lifeguard
like people's lives on the line but it's
like you're you're drawing on demand and
you have to make people happy otherwise
you don't get paid so you don't get
otherwise you don't make money and they
monitor how much money every person
makes so so if you draw someone and the
person like is refused it they can
refuse it yeah
Wow yeah so um but one of the scary
things is the interview because I came
in and they're like the guy interviewing
me this is like draw me have you
practiced character atures before going
in like YouTube or something so they
didn't did they provide on-the-job
training yes okay but not there not
until after the interview oh my gosh so
I'm just like trying to draw this guy's
face I'm like I drew stuff but
caricatures I've never done like that
style before because there's a very
distinct style yeah big head like
boulders yeah yeah it's it's like it's
just very distinct there's like a few
noses a few eyes but there's a very like
when you look at a photo just about the
exaggeration and the cartoon Enis yeah
of it it's got a very distinct look and
I drew more like slightly animate kind
of style stuff so great if he's like
draw mean II just drawn that's like an
enemy boy never drew guys I only drew
girls I was like oh God
draw him as an enemy girl and like so
far one of the things was after I
finished he was like you know what would
you do to improve it and I don't
remember most of what I said but like
the one thing I remember you just
blacked out
a long time ago I was like I was like 17
or 16 yeah but one thing I remember was
I said like I wish I had um different
line thicknesses cuz I drew this all
with the same line thickness and I feel
like it'd be a lot more interesting if
like some lines or thinner and some
lines were thicker and that like really
impressed him because like line
thickness is a huge thing in caricatures
because you use the thickness to like
hint at shadows it's like the thickness
of the line is also a way of adding
shadows mmm oddly like the line under
your nose is gonna have its gonna start
thin and then get thick and then go thin
again because the thicker part that's
where there's a little shadow under your
nose and same ones like your chin it's
gonna have like a thicker line under
there and there's all these different
things about it so when you draw do you
draw two different thicknesses or do you
have a you have you can twist it to make
it thinner or thicker it's um it's it's
like a brush
oh yeah the marker is almost like a
brush where it's kind of flexible and it
comes to a point but if you angle it
then it's thick so it's almost like a
modular modular Ithaca drew did you
sketch it and then go do you go straight
to marker you go straight to marker
there is no pencil there is no do-over
and you have to be able to do a face in
two to three minutes max so it's like
two or three minutes for a face you know
five or seven minutes if you're gonna
color the face five or so minutes if
it's black and white face and body and
then like eight minutes if it's full
body color mmm which is like that's a
lot of pressure yeah and I don't like to
work fast I like to take my time I don't
like people watching me when I draw it's
like all the things you don't like and I
just thought it'd be a cool job cuz I
knew two people who had done it and it
was like related haha and I did once I
got the feel for it I didn't like it um
it's also hard cuz like as a caricature
artist you have to decide am I gonna be
a nice caricature artist am I gonna be a
mean caricature a nice one oh of course
I was a nice one most people were nice
ones but we had some that were kind of
but it's like because what you're doing
essentially is you're looking at these
person's features and for every at least
this is how I was trained for every
feature there's a certain set of lines
and you do those lines in a certain way
and you train yourself like I can I can
do an eye like a caricature style
eyeball with my eyes closed I know
exactly where to start I know which
lines are thin which lines are thick I
know how to adjust it and so like you
have just like the same way you will
draw an eye but then if this person has
very large eyes or like upturned eyes or
downturned eyes or very small eyes or
squinty eyes you're gonna like do the
exact same lines no matter what
basically and then just like adjust them
mmm you know in like Skyrim and in those
it's like the phaser is dragging the
sliders to make them like big jaw little
jaw a little weak jaw like the nose is
always the exact same type of lines like
the mouth the exact same it's all the
same lines you just and you do them in
the same order every time and that's how
you get really fast so like eventually I
did get pretty good they're still like
like certain types of people that were
easier for me to drop it anyway so it's
all people use just no bald people
sucked oh really yeah I liked girls with
hair you know I like drawing hair yeah
so I liked I liked and I liked young
girls cuz I just like drawing long hair
basically it was a guy with long hair
I'd like drying him too but also girls
were easier for me to draw because I'd
drawn a lot of girls it's easier for me
to make a drawing look feminine rather
than masculine mm-hmm
but of course had to learn how to do it
I was 50% of the client yeah um but uh
yeah since you're looking at that
person's feature and then deciding
whether you downplay it or because you
can't like play up every single thing
you have your side like oh they got a
big mouth and tiny eyes or whatever but
you could you could be mean about it or
nice about it like you can make them
look better than they do in your life or
worse than they realize
but I was always a nice one because you
know I wanted don't ya actually no we
didn't get tipped what no I feel like a
caricature artist that'd be the perfect
opportunity to get tips no sometimes
people would give us stuff for free like
they'd like get a like oh it was always
dumb stuff it was like oh I won this
like prize over here and I don't want it
you ask hold this yeah I don't remember
getting tips that's so interesting
but uh oh man
and my first one of the like worst times
actually it had nothing to do with
drawing people it was just my first like
weak there you know I was trying to like
get to know people and like there's a
few different booths around and you'd be
stationed at like one booth for the day
but you could walk around on your break
yeah go see other people so when I was
on my break the person I was with took
me to like ride one of the rides yeah
cuz we could on our break or just any
time over the summer we had a free pass
we could come ride the rides and so I
was like you're not sure you know I'm
trying to like be friendly and stuff and
it was a spinny ride oh no dizzy just
thinking about it I was in it this is
like San Antonio hot hot so hot and
Fiesta Texas is like in a quarry like
there's no wind it's just like that like
what is what is the word like the
blacktop on pavement asphalt I thought
that asphalt asphalt sauce oh that ass
smell and like we did the spinny ride
and then like we went to go see other
people at one of the booths near the
spinny ride and I was just like hi and I
was so dizzy and I was so hot and I was
so sweaty and I was like I'm I'm gonna
throw up it was like everything in me to
not throw up and then like they wanted
me to draw over there while I was over
there just to kind of like see my style
and like do you we would often do like
test drawings and stuff so just like sat
down did you like practice and I was
like I don't feel like I like somehow
made it through but I was like I'm from
that point oh
or I would never do any rides on my
break no matter what yeah cuz I know one
one spinny ride can throw me off for a
day done for a whole day yeah the whole
day ruined yeah
whole day ruined and just imagine that
like in the heat and you're trying to
work no I'm getting like hot and sweaty
just thinking about it oh well there
actually was a problem with people like
like one of my one of my friends that
works there like passed out a couple
times because you're not allowed to
leave your booth and you're not allowed
to sit unless you're drawing so you have
to stand you have to be at your booth so
you can't like go get water you can't
sit down and it's you know hundred you
didn't have water bottles with you I
mean we did with somebody like run out
oh my gosh you know so I have one I have
a friend that passed out twice they like
fall and hit their head on the asphalt
really slowly like sat down oh yeah as
she was passing out or like as it was
coming on yeah so she didn't like fall
and crack her head or anything but it's
pretty bad yeah it like became a problem
I never I never passed out but it was it
was so hot fry because you're really
responsible and refill your water on
every single break but yeah it was it
was pretty fun every now and then I
haven't done in a long time but um like
a good way to practice cuz like the
worst thing you can do to practice is to
draw a generic face hmm
because your that's not what the job is
you know a generic face is just like
it's like the opposite have you ever
done a caricature of me
I have not hmm I don't like drawing
beards hahaha okay so I'll save ya
shaven I'll do a character okay I used
to like I to practice I would go through
magazines mm-hmm and do you like
celebrities and stuff mm-hmm
or like models just you know cuz that's
who's in magazines so if I found like a
big enough picture but I liked doing
celebrities cuz then I could show
somebody and be like who is this if I
got if I did it well so I could like
show my parents and be like who is this
nice um I think the last time I did that
was just for fun
I
did it like over Christmas or sometime
when we were visiting my parents in
Atlanta oh I think I think the last
caricature I've seen you do was actually
for my sister for a birthday card or
something oh are you doing a sketch of
her face for some reason I'm the worst
because I have a beard beard short hair
yeah so you said the beards are you with
flowing locks oh yeah yeah yeah all
right yeah so so the team that there's a
lot of options you could do like color
no color face no or like full body and
everything yeah and I think that so did
you the amount you get so you were just
an hourly employee okay so you didn't
get paid more for doing more expensive
things
no no but oh my gosh doing the full
bodies was like like I didn't mind doing
faces doing full bodies is often really
hard and I I would like desperately try
to direct people in a certain direction
because that's so interesting because
you're not you're not incentivized to
charge more than no oh you just want
it's like you're not sent avise to
charge you tell them you don't even
incentivize to do it like draw people
yeah well I mean like I like doing cuz
otherwise you're bored I think maybe I
mean maybe there was like part of my
money that came from it I don't remember
cuz I do remember like trying to upsell
people like there was some reason but it
could have just been because I was a
goody two-shoes document how many sales
you made huh so they still like
monitored how well you didn't
interesting so I could have just been
upselling for that whoever number one
Kalyn I think I was Wow yeah I think I
was actually like pretty high up there
that's awesome but yeah when people
wanted you to do full-body stuff they
good
take it ask for anything even worse okay
when you when you learn how to drive it
faces you okay like I said it's like
there's a specific way we were trained
to do eyes a specific way we were
changing noses and you just adjust but
if somebody's like I want to be a
princess riding a motorcycle I'm like I
don't know how to drop and then you just
have to like do your best and you didn't
have smartphone so you couldn't look at
reference images no you're just like you
know and like you can draw it okay and
try to distract by other stuff yeah but
or try to like oh well just cover most
of it with her princess dress yeah you
know just show the wheels and the
friends mortices show the wheel spinning
kicking up smoke you often did have to
do stuff like that like oh somebody
wanted to be on a jet ski
well splashing water is gonna cover
two-thirds of that jet yeah cuz cuz
that's really hard just like you're
drawing a whole scene and background and
everything you do like the outfit you
have to do you know whatever props and
stuff they're asking for and like if
it's not something you've drawn before
it's really hard to just like in your
mind think of that thing and draw it
even if like you you can picture it
generally when you think about like the
details and how they go together on a 2d
drawing yeah I know you should do like
request drawings with your brother where
like you'd like like say something
completely random and nonsensical did
that come from character to practice
that you're doing request drawings
before yeah yeah yeah that was that was
kind of stressful doing the full-body
ones right it was a little fun job it's
like you have some nostalgia for it of
like simpler times
not really in terms of like simpler
times I I wish that it was a skill I
still like practice because I think it's
cool but at the same time it's also
something that I like have avoided
telling people around me because the
first thing
happens if you like mention that you see
artists everybody wants a caricature of
them and then you're like well I don't
have my markers I like you look you
can't I don't I cannot do it without my
special markers that have like the bendy
tip yeah you know cuz I can't get my
different line thicknesses I mean I can
but it's like very hard after like force
it yeah like go back and make certain
lines thicker and it just doesn't look
as good and then you're like it's harder
to draw someone you know in a lot of
ways you're so familiar with their face
that like it's hard to fit them into the
formula and like if it's not totally
right you're like no that's right but a
stranger you like yeah
oh man sometimes people would bring
pictures like printed out pictures of
like oh can you draw like my kid or
something but they're not here or like
my having your face we're suppose to
small pictures of babies yeah and you're
like all the babies generic baby
template you just whip out basically
that's so interesting yeah yeah so so so
you didn't ever do Six Flags
no no but you didn't ever like ride the
rides in Six Flags but didn't you like
use the the water yeah yeah my friend
who works there and I would would go and
do the water park yes that's way better
than the land part anyway it's
especially during the summer yeah
exactly that's like we didn't really
want to run into coworkers so and
there's no caricatures in the water park
part of it so we just float the lazy
river for hours that's all we did so I'm
just floated the lazy river it was nice
I do look back on that fun yeah yeah
there's something about like summer and
like water attractions this is like
inspires nostalgia it could be like
beach lake pools whatever just something
about like the hot Sun but you're cold
because like you're evaporating the
water like that like memory just makes
me happy yeah yeah I don't actually know
how I got this job I don't know
after lifeguarding so yeah i lifeguarded
for three summers then i went to college
and then the first year I came back from
college I wasn't able to get an
internship yet so this is summer after
freshman year summer after sophomore
summer after junior year I did two
different internships for my that's real
job level stuff and those were other
other stories perhaps you know very
corporate stuff lots of wasted time
presentations were like it's like your
summer project is to like do this
research put together this thing and
then like nothing comes from it and
you're like that was a complete waste of
time
and there I I just believed in my
project anyway it's different thing
different thing in a pottery place the
pottery place
I just don't maybe it was a friend of a
friend or something like that by somehow
I had said working at this pottery
studio people would come in and paint
yeah and then you fire them yeah and
also III those are so cool though those
were pretty fun and you could get some
really really cool effects if you spent
the time but like I actually didn't 100%
like dealing with customers cuz I was
like so I get into some customer stories
later on but like I just it just
bothered me and I didn't have like a
high BS like battery that I could like
fill up or something I don't know I just
wasn't the most patient perhaps I might
say so I I turned myself into a
specialist of the kiln so specialist of
the kiln so I would take all of the
stuff that people made load it arrange
it okay I took pictures of the
arrangements I made because you're like
fire and the kiln is very expensive
because you're heating up yeah so it's
like you you you like will get
everything of a certain height you'd lay
it all out you did an arrangement and
all of them would have these little
spikes that you'd turn it on and you
build up the next layer then build up
the next layer and build up the next
layer so any ever not that I remember
now well um yeah so not that I remember
so it didn't affect me so you're just
really good well I was really good so
yeah I'm stack everything and then um
you know when when so if you guys don't
know how this works there's a lot of
like pre-done templates like a bowl or a
spoon holder or a mug or whatever it is
that are just missing the painted glaze
yeah so people come in and they paint
but that's just the color I still have
to do I'm not sure if it was multiple
dips but I had to do the clear outside
on top so after people are done painting
then we dip it and it looks like green
but it fires clear so I had to do all of
the dipping the post-processing of the
clear and then I had to fire it and then
I had to clean up the sharp edges
afterwards because when it when it fires
the colors on there then the clear is
over it but there's like spikes like on
a mug I'm gonna hold do this for the PAS
people this watching on YouTube but
there's three spikes that the cup is
resting on when you fire it there's
three shards of glass you kinda have to
break it off then there's three shards
of glass on the bottom like shooting out
like resting on nails so I have to go go
around with the Dremel and like Dremel
that off and that's also why I'm like
paranoid about eye protection because I
think once a shard of glass shot out and
like I'm not sure if it like penetrated
my eye or what I went to like the
ophthalmologist and everything but I was
worried that I'd like stabbed my eye was
I did glass shard from this now my
actually been wearing two levels of
protection why I didn't like OSHA OSHA
yeah without safety glasses but like you
know safety glasses there's gaps yeah so
I should have been wearing a whole face
shield yeah yeah yeah it's also you
don't want that glass embedding anywhere
in your face no yeah how do bad so yeah
but you know like general customer
service things like people having
unreasonable demands and also I've had a
place like this it's not like close like
I'm trying clothing stores there's other
issues that might come up when you talk
about hot topic but like the place where
I was working a lot of the end results
depended on someone's skill yeah and so
they didn't like it were they upset
sometimes sometimes well I'm sorry that
you suck sucks to suck but I also think
that like one thing that kind of
bothered me is when parents would like
drop off kids that were too young and
this uses as a babysitting service I
think sometimes like yeah there's like
an edge of like what's acceptable like
of course parents dropping off their
16-year olds that's okay
parents dropping off two-year-olds well
I mean like obviously duh you know but
like there are some borderline cases
where they might be like 10 or something
well I mean like imagine like dropping
off a kid who shouldn't be there like
I'm not sure what a borderline is I'm
just gonna say ten just to choose a
number I'm not sure I would think like a
ten year old's parent usually should
have some an adult with them yeah but
like you're in a pottery place and like
the the person may not be good at
painting they may be doing things wrong
they may be using up too much color
there they're surrounded by lots of
breakable things yeah they're using up
supplies which are costly you know so
it's like there are definitely a lot of
borderline cases where like and like
when they drop the kids off you don't
know whether the kid is gonna be a
problem kid or not you know but like the
biggest clientele where kids and parents
having like like occupying their kids
time not many adults came in like my mom
would take
brother and I yeah a lot of cats were
responsible and we're with their kids
and stuff like that but some would just
like cuz it was next like like like a
grocery store so I think some parents
were just like okay okay I'm gonna drop
the kid off at the good the pottery
place keep them entertained for 20 or 30
minutes while I go shop and listen to a
podcast or something like borderline
cases like that so it's like there were
some things that like we put it in
particular had to deal with and you know
there's a lot of people dissatisfied
with various aspects that are outside of
our control and I'm like [ __ ] also like
the firing process they didn't
understand it and I'm like well we kind
of explain when you come in and stuff so
I don't know it sounds like you like
lifeguarding better I think I like like
writing a lot more honestly I think it
was nice though to get a customer
service facing job it was you know it
was interesting learning like about like
the cash register and like you know
doing the deposits and like you know
running the store in that way like
opening closing doing like like
businessí like cool things like Texas
hmm when you closed you had to take the
til with all the money in it like to the
place you're supposed to drop it off
yeah and you don't do that until the
park is empty and you had to go through
like the back ways so going like through
the back at an empty theme park holding
a giant bag of money is like kind of
scary but cool dude cool yeah yeah it
was just like always kind of creepy and
weird yeah I think I feel like an adult
should be doing this yeah but it was
just kind of creepy being in like an
empty theme park yeah yeah what was your
stall mate with you no oh really it one
person okay so there's no need to keep
two people there for the closing process
yeah
it wasn't something I did all the time
but and sometimes you were at a booth
alone wow that's interesting yeah
closing up was kind of nice it like we
would put on music and would clean and
like you know there's always like the
people that you're with are like what
makes or breaks jobs a lot of it so so
the people that was with of the pottery
studio we're good but I liked
lifeguarding the well certain parts of
it it was also stressful so I like this
job the most yeah great coworkers yes
great flexibility yes good good business
partner won't work life balance
[Laughter]
so people who watch the gaming streams
know this but I don't know if you guys
know this but I used to like I don't
want to say I was an emo kid but I
dressed like an emo kid yes different
cuz cuz you were you your personality
your outlook on life a lot has been very
careful your just remember has been the
same throughout your life but you did
love the fashion side I love the music
oh yeah yeah I liked the music and I
like to dress that way but I was also
like a very very good student like I did
all of my homework I didn't have
conflicts with my parents or family I
had like you know there there was no
like unhappiness with like I mean of
course there's stuff that like would bum
me out
yeah there was drama stuff with like
school and friends and whatever there's
normal life stuff but like generally I
was I was just like a kind of shiny
nerdy kid but I like to dress like super
emo and so I shopped a lot at hot just
super emo oh we haven't shared any of
those pictures yeah we like you know
plaid skirts and combat boots and like
like all the
armbands with like the studs and the
studded pyramid belt side safety pins of
my ears like all out like I was a little
Hot Topic kid and so so I started
working at Hot Topic because you you
liked the store yeah I wanted the
employees ha ha ha ha and I needed a job
like the Sun brooch in high school and
college yep so I started working there
and like it was kind of intimidating
because like because I like was actually
like a really good student and like you
know like I felt like I was like I
dressed like the other people that works
there oh but it was kind of a poser oh
yeah because I was actually just like I
wasn't rebellious at all you know what I
think there was there no rebel in me um
I was just like a good kid um he's
always felt like I wasn't quite like
it's cool yeah they're people that
people might have been thinking that to
maybe maybe you know um but it was
mostly just like folding clothes and
greed they always put me in the front to
greet customers cuz I was very never
like work the register I worked the
register some which I actually preferred
doing that because I didn't have to be
as cheery they they would put me often
up at the front cuz I was like the
cheery aspersion there I had just burn
off like you know yeah because they were
quite tired in there I got this put the
new person out their new friend and I
was like the least intimidating
yes like I I don't know I think I was
like less than to my knees I didn't have
like I had a bunch of ear piercings but
I didn't have like facial piercings I
didn't have like tattoos anything like
that so I was like maybe a little bit
more friendly to the parents coming in I
don't know but um but I mostly do that
there's a lot of standing there there's
a lot of standing there telling people
did you know about our 20% off sale on
combat boots today haha buy one get one
free pyramid belts I feel like I'd go
insane out of boredom it was kind of
boring the the plus sides were the music
was great huh so you always had like
good fun music
um but most of it was boring cuz you're
just like folding clothes because people
are messy no I learned how to fold
t-shirts really fastest still got that
skill that was some good I could fold a
tee a mean t-shirt um but it's mostly
just like that letting people into the
dressing room you know so if you kind of
alternate between like door greeter and
then fold some soft which I really like
it's mostly just like you have to be on
you have to be smiling for hours how
many hours of your shifts um I mean they
were like full day chefs I was working
full time well not maybe not full time
out like any given day was mostly like a
full day shift so it's like 8:00 to 6:00
or something yes I'm like that oh wow or
sometimes it'd be like the evening shift
um one time and I was like this is
relatively early when I started it might
have been like just a few days in um
like this a woman like is walking by was
in the front of the store and this woman
was walking by and she kind of like
stops outside the store uh looks up kind
of like looks into it and then like kind
of starts to keep keep walking and she
can have like a frown on her face mhm
and then she comes back and she grabs a
shirt off the hanger and leaves and I
was like uh uh you know I'm like looking
around and then she comes back and she's
like well you failed the test she was a
like a district manager or something and
she was like when you when I was walking
by and you saw me looking into the store
he shows that hello welcome to Hot Topic
please come in did you know about these
sales and of course I didn't because
like she was kind of far out of the
store and she had big frown on her face
like she looked at it like she didn't
like it sounds like I'm not gonna talk
to that lady it was like and then you
let me come up and steal a shirt but I
was just like who is this woman I'm
terrified I almost started crying Oh a
few days into it and I was like oh my
god I can't handle
so a few days into the job and it's and
it's like it's not like someone who was
gonna try to steal the shirt would do it
that way then we're gonna just like walk
up in front of me and like take it and
walk out you know what I mean like I
feel like we have like more confidence
than like someone yeah would be feeling
it would have or something yeah it was
just like I just I felt very personally
attacked like run after her and tackle
her I call for security I guess so but
like I don't know it was I panicked I
froze up I I failed my test I still kept
the job which was fine but like she
would occasionally come back to like
check on thanks and I was just like I
did not like deism she was in there I
feel like she always didn't like me oh
my gosh it was very traumatizing so she
only got to do the test once the test
was only once I don't know if she ever
did anything to other people I don't
know if she did to me because when she
came by she saw that I was Neil yeah and
I maybe she had tested other people in
the past I don't remember any hiring any
new people while I was still there so I
don't remember people being there that
we're newer than me but maybe they were
um I don't know uh address me it was
really mean um but on the plus side I
got a 40 percent off employee discount
all of my money Hot Topic
I was just like all my lunch breaks I
would eat super quickly and then I would
come back to my own store and try on all
the stuff I'd been eyeballing all
get-out in my brain like you would I'm
gonna try on today literally spend my
whole page which is weird because I'm
not like a big spender but I think like
I knew I wouldn't have this job for
super long it was just like a temporary
job before college yeah and I was like
well the smart thing is to buy
everything now well I have this discount
you know it was 40% off so so
interesting question now that I'm like
thinking back on this one of the things
that we do with Evan and Caitlin is we
sell merchandise you can go to shop
everything Caitlin
come to check that out nice promo here
but it's so interesting because now
we're selling t-shirts and a while ago
in the past you sold t-shirts at Hot
Topic I did this was unrelated to me
working at Hot Topic I think I might
have mentioned that I used to work there
what I like like signed up for it but
one thing I noticed when I was working
there is could I used to follow a lot of
artists online like back on like
deviantART and stuff I'm not even part I
know and I there was like one of the
artists that I followed one day I
noticed her shirts showed up at Hot
Topic and I was like my mind was blown I
was like I followed this girl and here's
her mermaid on a t-shirt what how this
is so crazy and so then I looked into it
and like you could submit your designs
to be on Hot Topic t-shirts yeah and it
was like there was it wasn't heavily
advertised and you had to do it through
corporate and stuff um but so I like
emailed them and sent some of my artwork
and like sent them my website with all
my art and they liked it and they picked
out a few design so I had two t-shirts
and a hoodie at Hot Topic for a limited
time so crazy yeah it's cool I have you
have any of them left yeah yeah yeah I
mean I've seen the t-shirts yeah I have
them here yeah it was really cool like
for that season - do you remember what
the deal was did you get like a
percentage of the sale it wasn't much it
wasn't like one percent it was like
fifteen percent I think was like fiver
- it was a single-digit yeah yeah but I
didn't have to do anything yeah I just
like it was art I had already designed I
didn't have to make any adjustments to
it it was just like here's my art if you
like it you can put it on t-shirts they
give examples yeah I did get some
samples oh yeah yeah yeah it was cool it
was kind of unrelated cuz it was I think
freshman year of college that I did that
yeah so it wasn't actually related to
that job but it was still cool so
another thing that
people might know by now about you is
you love Halloween
so the hot topic do anything interesting
for Halloween well for the entire month
of October we got to dress up oh that's
cool so I had an entire month so fun and
you had to get like kind of creative
because coming up with a month of
costumes that's like a lot of costumes
together
how many costumes would you wear did you
just like put together two or three no I
had like at least ten um yeah
why no and it was all stuff I would like
I mean there's kind of like interpretive
costumes yeah you know it was like I'm
gonna be a like a Gothic Lolita doll you
know and I'd like just like wear
accessories that kind of worked with it
or whatever you know and it was all it
was like everything was kind of like Hot
Topic II themed stuff and I would use a
lot of their clothes yeah part of it
they sold Halloween costumes so like I
had a couple like costume costumes and
then most of it was like I would put
together I think you were too good for
them you you you you went to work for
them
you bought their own stuff to advertise
for them and then you would spend hours
of time and thought putting together
costumes and makeup to like go for them
again at the store to sell more stuff
for them the fun the fun part was
dressing up yeah
shopping probably all had like you the
costume is pretty practical I'm
comfortable because he also had to be
I'm and stand around them yeah I gotta
have shoes and all that stuff um so yeah
I had to be ID to be pretty comfortable
but then the weird thing is when I
stopped working there I felt so awkward
about quitting like well cuz you're too
nice well and I hadn't worked there
super long like it was maybe it was less
than a year maybe six months that I
worked there and then it was just like
too much to keep up with work and school
you know and it was like why am I doing
this yeah you know um but I felt so
awkward quitting that I stopped going in
and that's when I started dressing
differently
like who can get new Hot Topic stuff
because well I get how to change my
style like in college I I had some
remnants of my stuff you're
transitioning now transitioning out
that's so interesting because like I
felt awkward going into the store I
didn't like shopping for things online
because like I couldn't try them on it's
so funny yeah that's probably the only
reason I'm not still dressed so so how
many months so I know you did during the
summer before too but how many months
did he do school and work at the same
time I stopped around the holiday after
the holidays hmm the guy helps out with
like the holiday craziness and I stopped
in for that so it was like the first
semester of college I was still working
there oh wow oh oh during college when
you met me I was working a hot topic ah
that's crazy so let me try to think so
you'd go to college and then you would
work weekends and evenings Wow
I mean I had reduced hours by the time I
did college it wasn't it was like half
shifts not full shift and it was only
like maybe two times a week or something
it wasn't a ton but it was still enough
cuz like the first period of college
that's like so busy and there's so much
you can do and like I would have I would
have had such a hard time like putting
time to something that like wasn't
advancing College yeah stop yeah it
didn't last super long but you you
worked instead of quitting during the
summer you just felt awkward quitting
after summer yeah cuz I started it in
the summer well that's what most people
do they start in summer and then it at
the end at the end but you just felt
weird quitting my fault awkward out of
awkwardness yeah
so great so funny
so funny it's so good okay well I think
that wraps up our teenage job stories
yeah actually move on to thing of the
week it's a thing of the week the time
thing is a lot for me every time you
shouldn't say that because every time
you say like oh the timing was a little
off for me people who are watching might
see that you're bobbing your head not to
the timing of the thing in the week
music but people who are just listening
have no like there's no there's nothing
auditory indication of my head swing off
to you know during the week I'll just
like keep my head very still just keep
your head still don't don't Bob to the
music improperly system beats in your
head just um just go with it don't make
excuses no okay yeah yeah don't be
ashamed of my poor rhythm yeah no you're
good okay cool so my theme of the week
is video game controllers so we have a
lot of different video game controllers
we have Xbox we have PlayStation we have
like I had a Bluetooth ones we had to
switch all sorts of wireless controllers
wired controllers all of that and you
know I'm all about multi-purpose I'm all
about reducing I'm all about like trying
to streamline things so I found these
controllers they are bluetooth but you
can put them in different modes you can
put them in two modes for Windows for
Mac for switch and enslie they work on
the switch too so you know that that
loves us to replace some of the
controllers that we have that we were
using so I could you know get rid of a
lot of controllers now if we've fully
switched over to this system and I'm
just trying out which one is best and
you know I'm using them for travel and
everything like that because sometimes
when we're going over my family's house
or your parents house how do I bring
these controllers over so I can play
games with the people who are over at
these houses so I found one system that
I really like it's the SN 30 Pro and the
SN 30 Pro Plus so one's like
small ones like a bigger dia one is like
SNES controller it's like kind of flat
and just like that little puck type
thing and one is kind of more like
modern and has the handle grips coming
out and stuff like that so I just think
that it's a really neat system it
charges with USB see great battery life
great clickability the the triggers last
like you know the triggers are great all
the buttons are really great they're
really durable I'm just really impressed
with the system so far and I just really
like that it's a single thing that you
can use for all sorts of things and I
love stuff like that pulling to both
sides is just so that people can see the
two different versions cool yeah my
thing of the week is another present I
had put on my Christmas wish list and
got for Christmas and it sees LED
candles they're actually the video that
we released our patio makeover video at
the end of it I used them in like the
lanterns because I didn't want to deal
with real again but so I've been trying
to find the perfect LED candle for a
really long time like since they came
out but you know the ones before it's
like the flame was just like a flame
shapes a little bulb and even when it
flickered it was just like the light
would turn on and off and they were a
plasticy and like there's never unless
you're really far away they never really
quite looked right and then when we were
on vacation once the place we were at
had this new type and they're not really
new anymore they were just new at the
time but so that's why I ended up
putting on my list cuz they're finally
not ridiculously expensive when we
discover them there were eighty dollars
for a pack of three candles and now it's
like and I'll pull up the price but
we'll link to them mmm I think it's like
[Music]
2000 we should have more of those I knew
I wanted to like test them so if they're
on Amazon the brand is like you were why
I wer flameless candles here's the two
things that make them awesome or they
make them different than like the ones I
have it's adding more to make them
different from the ones before so the
flame part
is actually it actually physically moves
it like flutters there's there's
mechanical move there's mechanical
movement yeah to where like the little
thing coming up where the flame would be
flutters and there's a light shining on
it so like it's so much more realistic
like it's a double tank the room kind of
flickers like there's candles in it like
it should be and you see the
quote-unquote flame actually physically
moving not just like a bulb shaped like
a flame that is flickering off another
ring with lower and brighter light yeah
so that is super cool in the other thing
is they're covered in wax hmm so like
they have the right Sheen when you touch
them it's like touching a candle like
they're just really cool so the seconds
with three different sizes they're
remote-controlled we realize that our TV
remote also convenient yeah so we'll
link to those when I think of the week
yeah but I think you're right when we
first saw them we wanted them but
they're too expensive but like that's
really reasonable yeah yeah yeah all
right guys thanks so much for tuning in
to today's evident Galen podcast so far
this is the first time we've taken like
a little bit of a break between them
well we took a break like around the
holidays but this is the first one since
we announced that we were gonna do the
slightly more would you schedule this is
I think it's good for a like our mental
stuff yeah it's good for mental stuff
okay hopefully lets us spend a little
bit more time thinking about like a
topic that would be good good good like
story worthy topic yeah yeah like this
is a really fun one too let's appreciate
you guys hang out with us and tuning in
to this week's episode and we'll look
forward to seeing you next time